so as we get into spider-verse here what
we're going to find is that we're going
to encounter a wide array of different
verses of spider-man and in fact it's
going to be absolute pandemonium trying
to keep track of them all so in a lot of
instances you're going to hear me refer
to two individuals like this version of
spider-man or things like that now with
spider or what guess with assassin
spider-man with an old man spider-man
and especially with the earth-616
version of Peter Parker will address
them as such what we're going to do with
the earth-616 version of spider-man is
we're going to address him as Peter
Parker that way we can add really
separate him from everybody else but in
addition what I'd like you to remember
is that while all of this is going on in
the entire spider-verse conflict while
all these videos are taking place the
incursions are still happening the New
Avengers and the Cabal led by name of
the Submariner are still trying to end
the incursions and so the impending
destruction of the Marvel multiverse is
still undergoing and so just kind of
keep that in the back of your head while
all this is going on because I feel like
that would add this route I guess the
sense of a grander scale to the entire
conflict that's taking place in the
Marvel continuity at the moment but what
we do here as we start spider-verse is
that we pick up with Peter Parker from
earth 449 and of course this version of
Peter Parker is woken up by Jay jonah
Jameson in the same fashion that the
earth-616 version would in the sense
that when he answers the phone call from
Jay jonah Jameson Jameson is just
screaming into his ear and what this
version of JJ jonah Jameson tells him is
that there's some kind of a person who's
wreaking havoc at Armstrong Park and he
wants Peter Parker to go photograph it
and so Peter Parker as both spider-man
and his normal self working for what we
would assume to be the Daily Bugle then
this timeline dawns ah's outfit and goes
to Armstrong Park and when he gets there
he realizes that what's actually
happening here is that more loon is
attacking the park now again he doesn't
really know who more loon is in fact he
asked through this person is a more loon
responds by saying that every time he
encounters a new version of spider-man
they always ask the same question who
are you and what do you want and so what
we see is that more loon is easily able
to overpower this version of spider-man
and the
version of spider-man is killed and
consumed and so what we do is we jump to
earth 1 then what we find is that we
pick up with Verna and damos and of
course the other brother and sister of
more loon but what they also do is they
give us some really cool insight into
the family life of the inheritors in the
sense that there's trouble in paradise
here they don't really care for more
learn too much mostly it seems to be
because they might be jealous of the
fact that more loon is I considered the
favorite bother father but what happens
is that after malloon has feasted on
spider-man from earth for 49 he comes
back to earth 1 and what they do is of
course they greet him they ask him which
spider-man he had chosen to consume this
time and he says it doesn't really
matter that all the Earth's are the same
now what Verna does is she comments here
and she says it he she keeps telling
himself that and this is really
interesting because what happens is more
loon begins to question this more loon
begins to ask what it is she's referring
to now what happens is that Davos tells
a more loon that Verna along with damos
and everybody else has been able to tell
that the 1:1 reality that more loon has
been avoiding it's earth-616 now more
loon initially tells damos that he's
simply saving this universe for the last
but in truth i would go as far as to
speculate this is not the case but in
fact more loon is actually scared to go
to the earth-616 continuity to deal with
that version of spider-man because as we
know spider-man had defeated more loon
on a couple of occasions and so because
of this I would surmise that more loon
really doesn't want to undergo the
process of dying and being cloned to
return against once more and so what we
do is we switch to the actual earth-616
version of spider-man now what happens
the spider-man wakes up to Cyndi moon
standing over him and what spider-man
does here I guess what Peter Parker does
here is he gives us some really cool
insight into into Cyndi moon but this is
actually really interesting the way the
model does this in truth I would go as
far as to say this is probably a
continuity error on behalf of Marvel and
the reason why is because what Peter
Parker says is that Cyndi moon claims to
have been bitten by the same same spider
as Peter Parker
but what we know here is that during the
events of original sin this was actually
true that the thing that Peter Parker
had seen when the orb had blasted
multiple superheroes with the secrets of
The Watcher was a Peter Parker had
learned that his spider had bitten
somebody else and so the
that he would convey and say the Cindy
moon is claiming this would indicate
that he doesn't believe that it's true
indicating that he doesn't know whether
it's true or not so again just kind of
something to keep in the back of your
head again this is something that's not
that really isn't something to go too
deep into I guess but it really just
highlights the kind of continuity errors
that we had seen in Marvel Comics but of
course what happens is that Cindy moon
and Peter Parker begin I just talking
with one another and again what we see
is that the pheromones that are picked
up or I guess dispersed between the two
of them really begin to draw the two of
them closer and this is something that
we had immediately picked up on doing
original sin then as soon as Peter
Parker had met Cindy moon he was
immediately drawn to her in a way that
he wasn't drawn to anybody else and what
they do is they really I guess they
begin to realize that for the most part
they have to find some way to get out of
here that they can't stay in the room of
Peter Parker anymore otherwise they will
dive back into the very heated romantic
and most likely sexual relationship they
had previously had and so what they do
is they leave the apartment of Peter
Parker and they head out into the city
and in the midst of traveling into the
city they come across a bank robbery now
what they do is of course they rob the
bank I'm sorry they they stop the bank
robbers and so on but while the bank
robbers are being stopped we also see
that spider-man is joined by a multitude
of other versions of spider-man and
spider-woman from different realities
now what happens is of course after the
bank robbers are defeated spider-man
begins asking them what they're doing
here and what's going on and what they
say is that the web of life is
converging on spider-man and spider-man
doesn't really know why he doesn't
really understand what's going on here
but what the group tells him is that
he's faced the inheritors before and
he's been successful in the sense that
he had faced more loan and he had won
now spider-man is a little shocked here
to learn that more elune is actually
coming back but what they tell him is
that is not more loon who's coming that
it's actually more loons brother damos
that what they had found was that a
portal or or some form of transportation
had been opened between the realm of
earth one were the inheritors reside and
the earth-616 universe and so what they
had done is they had followed this
version of or I guess the person of
damos to earth-616 in order to to one
and a save spider-man or Peter Parker
for what was going on and so what we do
is we jump to wonder gore mountain now
wonder gore mountain is of course the
home where the new warriors are
currently call
their home although I guess at this
point what Marvel tells us is that it's
what's left of the New Warriors and what
we do is we pick up with Scarlet Spider
now solid spider is currently being
attacked by by Deimos then white damos
does is a basically attempt to consume
him but before he's actually able to
kill him we see that spider Gwyn shows
up along with old man spider and a
couple other people and what happens is
that this group is able to save Scarlet
Spider but at the same time Bruce Banner
who is an alternate version of
spider-man from a different reality is
killed in the process and so what the
group does is they jump back to Earth 13
and the reason why they jump back to
earth 13 is because this is a safe haven
for all of the spider characters from
the various realities now again
spider-man is still very confused here
he still doesn't really know what's
going on here from his perspective he
suddenly just met up with all these
different versions of himself
and they've simply gathered him and then
taken him to a location while on the way
saving somebody else and so what he asks
is why is it the death or safe here why
is this place a safe haven when nowhere
else is and what happens is that cosmic
Spider Man appears now what cosmic
Spider Man tells Peter Parker is that
this is a safe place because of his
abilities but what Peter Parker also
deduces is that this is the version of
what he would have been like had he not
lost the enigma Force now the Enigma
force is the force that is possessed as
far as I understand by Captain universe
and in spectacular spider-man Peter
Parker had been possessed by Captain
universe and as a result he had been
able to wield the powers of the Enigma
force this version of Peter Parker from
Earth 13 this cosmic spider-man is what
Peter Parker would have become had he
not given up or lost possession of the
Enigma force along with Captain universe
and so again what captain universe says
or I'm sorry what a cosmic Spider Man
says here is that because he is so
powerful the inheritors would be foolish
to attempt to conquer them or to attack
them in that universe and so what he
says is that this is the safe haven this
is the one place where all the
characters can go to be safe with the
problem here is that his powers only
exist or they only I guess exist in
their current form of some measure of
omnipotence as long as he's within his
own reality if he leaves this reality
he'll lose his powers and he will only
have the powers of your regular
spider-man and so again what we see this
cosmic
spider-man's saying is that if it
becomes necessary he will leave this
reality and that again it most likely
will due to the coming battle now again
what spider-man says here is that he's a
little confused continuing to really be
overwhelmed here and he asks them about
what battle it is that they're talking
about and what cosmic spider-man says is
the reason why they brought him here is
because he is the best of them but
before we get too far and get too far
into that what we do here is we jump
jump into Miles Morales and while this
is going on we find that Verna is has
apparently arrived here - I guess attack
ultimate spider-man Miles Morales as
well as a Jessica drew and so what
happens is that before they're actually
able to commit this act we see that
assassin spider-man along with spider
punk arrived and they're able to rescue
Miles Morales and Jessica drew but
before Miles Morales leaves what he does
is he tells Verna that she has made this
personal that she has made this
something that he simply I guess cannot
walk away from because what she's done
is she's insulted the memory of Miles
Morales his mother by destroying her
tombstone and so what we find is that
assassin spider-man in spite of punctate
Miles Morales and and Jessica drew back
to the safe zone and when we get back to
the safe zone we of course again see
various versions of Spider Man meeting
up with each other but what's also
happening here is that Cindy moon is
conducting an experiment of her own what
Cindy moon is basically doing here if
she's walking around all these various
versions of Spider Man of Peter Parker
as well as Spider Woman and she's trying
to figure out if she can pick up and
really has the same kind of attraction
to them as she does to Peter Parker from
the earth-616 continuity but what she
find is that she doesn't now again this
gives us some really valuable insight
into the character of Cindy moon and
into how these various spider-man
function within their own native reality
in the sense that much like the Infinity
Gauntlet or the infinity gems that they
really seem to be at their peak in their
own reality but that these characters
really tie into other characters from
their own work from their native reality
more so than I do the other characters
but again we see that these various this
very begins splitting into teams they
begin splitting up separately now
initially a Peter Parker from earth-616
is paired with Cindy moon and Gwen Stacy
but he says no now Gwen
gwen stacy is really i guess i'm sure
she doesn't really know why it is a
peter parker doesn't want to be
partnered with her but of course we know
that the whole reason behind this is
because when stacy was killed in peter
parker's reality and so I think that
Peter Parker here is afraid that she may
be killed again and I would surmise he
doesn't want to actually see her die a
second time and of course we see the
Peter Parker turns down having Cindy
moon on his team because of the
attraction between the two of them would
be more of a distraction than anything
else but of course Cindy moon Stowe's
away on the team anyway and so what we
do is we find that Peter Parker's team
actually ends up in the spider-man 2099
universe now this is a very interesting
concept here because what we find is
that within this universe is Doctor
Octopus s superior spider-man and this
is basically a continuation of the team
that he had put together in edge of
spider-verse and what's really funny
here is that we basically have two
versions of spider-man from the same
universe from the same continuity from
earth-616 and the whole reason why this
had happened was really just as a way to
introduce as to what it was a Doctor
Octopus was doing during his time at
superior spider-man during the time gap
here and what he tells us is that for
months he had been working on a device
that would mask this signal or masked
the scent of these various spider-man
from the inheritors but the problem here
is that there are basically too many of
them here but what he also says is that
the sense of both Kaine and Cyndi moon
are much higher than anybody else and he
asks why this is the case now what old
man spider says is that the reason for
this is because they are unique to any
reality Cyndi moon is what's referred to
as the bride and in Kaine is referred to
as the other but before we're actually
able to get too far into this
explanation before we learn too much
more about this we again see Doctor
Octopus saying that they're going to
inevitably draw the attention of the
inheritors because there's too many of
them there and then we see that damos
arrives and so what damos does is he
begins attacking the various forms of
spider-man taking it in turn to do what
he can to kill them all because for him
he considers this some measure of a
succulent feast with that being said
we're gonna go ahead and ring this video
to an end I hope you guys enjoyed it if
you did let me know and I will catch you
guys later
peace be sure to follow me on Twitter
there you can keep up with all the
updates from comics explained and talk
to me directly
really